either one okay so i'm here with min lee
and what do you do here at the khan
academy i'm the lead of strategic
initiatives at Khan Academy and what are
some of these initiatives that are
strategic the initiatives that are
strategic include number one our summer
camp so running a summer camp this year
that is going to be in palo alto and
it's called the discovery lab that's one
of the strategic initiatives and why is
I mean why are we doing this well I
think I think the big reason why is that
we're known for online education you
know we are known to do the work in the
classroom so that teachers can free up
time to do projects but one of the
constant feedback that we get from the
teachers is that they don't know don't
know what projects to do in the
classroom now that the time is freed up
and so one of the intense of the summer
camp is to identify what are the
projects that are fun that are also
educational and interesting and not
force dedication my truly not by numbers
well paint by numbers and actually you
know you people find that you know they
actually learn something from it um so
identify what those projects are and
then scale that out online so it's kind
of a discovery lab for all involved the
kids will get cover and then we will
discover and then we'll discover what
works what's not what might be
appropriate for different ages and
things like that and what kind of stuff
are are y'all looking at to do are we
looking at to do so we are doing a
variety of things so one big thing is
that we're going to do a lot of Robotics
activities with the Lego Mindstorms kids
so learning about the mechanical
structures of robots learning about the
sensors how do you use sensors and then
you know probably doing some big
competition but you did a couple years
ago Lego sumo wrestling they go sumo
wrestling leave the kids be it was
amazing what they did they did a lot
more than I would have expected and it's
the Olympics this year okay so we can
make it very thematic um so robotics is
a big piece the second big pieces all
the math and music stuff that via does
so by and I had gone to a classroom a
couple months ago and we did a lot of
you know creating platonic solids solids
creating geometric shapes with students
you know and giving them the intuition
behind rather tangible because and
that's destra specially
three-dimensional yeah mathematics and
three-dimensional geometry it's kind of
hard to really get a
Apple sense with that without it being a
gerbil yeah yeah exactly you know if we
talk about things like you know if we
talk about a triangle being a strongest
shape why is a triangle strongest shape
right let's put one together let's put a
square together let's try and twist and
turn it and you realize all of this
right so do they want to believe it and
also they kind of get an intuition for
it and some of the other stuff like you
know random games and simulations yeah
yeah exactly am I going to do lots of
games and simulations probably secondary
trading markets let you did and then
some sort of economics training games
i'm trying to make up right now so hope
you'll be fun yeah no that's that's
that's that's exciting I would want to
go to this camp yeah and we'll figure
out what we'll figure out what and so
what until I interrupted you yeah that
the camp is one campus one thing the
second thing is in general international
strategy so how do we work with
international partners or international
schools who want to use kind of cat and
so there are people outside of and so
what's going on I mean you just went on
a recent trip yes yes I wanted a recent
trip so that many other many things
going on I think generally when people
hear about Khan Academy they're excited
which is great for us right and so
there's a lot of pool of wanting to use
Khan Academy in schools outside and
sometimes it's just a matter of just
getting people up to speed or just
saying oh no here's how you can use it's
really easy you know and then just
getting them started that's one thing
but then there are other bigger
implementations that people are doing so
for example just last week I was in the
state of Sonora in Mexico they are
giving out one laptop per child the oil
pcs to each student and then they're
also providing internet student in the
state the state of Sonora it's like
300,000 students or something yes yeah
so therefore providing each student with
a computer is starting of 10,000 first
um and I thought yes just last week but
each computer is labeled with the
child's name and the serial number so
they can track all those computers and
they also providing internet access is a
constitutional right and on top of that
in their portal they have put our cut
Academy's content both in Spanish and in
English so that the students can access
the content so that these are students I
mean these aren't just like urban
students that middle class this is you
saw his kids yeah so yeah we we started
off at a really indigenous location
which was called bacchum and you know
these are students who you know it's the
first time they've started using
computers
so they're going to have to sort of
learn computer literacy and then you
know we showed them some of the Khan
Academy content to do it do intrigued by
it I think it's you know just sort of
it's a big change process from there but
that's one other organizations you know
South Africa there's a conv youth
organization they just they're doing the
translations into the native language
and they're doing something this and
after-school program that's really
interesting so doing offline
implementations there a lot of exciting
things going on an international front
mostly volunteer-driven Wow well and and
and you know how did you end up here I
mean you know how did you um so you know
I you know I I was excited by the
mission the first time I heard about
Khan Academy and um my background is I
spent a couple years in social welfare
in the Singapore government really
focused in on low-income families that's
where you grew up singapore singapore
the same force where I grew up um and I
was there for the first 20 years of my
life yeah um it's York ago but you also
taught in Singapore and I did I did I
taught high school math um then I had
about 200 something almost 300 students
300 students that you were teaching it
no no separate separate closets doing
the same amount okay so you taught high
school math in Singapore and you also
worked for the government government was
on low income family a policy focus on
education and childcare Wow so there's a
little always you know I always felt I
needed to give back in some way after
that I went to mckinsey & company and I
did some management consulting work
hotshot consultant I attempted to be
epic you know five plus years of that I
decided to refer it back and this was a
good place to sort of merge the two
experiences and what what's it been like
so far I mean as it hasn't been what you
expected has been different better worse
um I keep telling everyone I know which
can be annoying sometimes but I tell
them is to you know it's the best job
I've ever had I love this job you said
even when I'm not in the room I say yes
i said it constantly i say it on my
facebook page i think my friends might
start getting annoyed about that but i
truly believe you know and I mean I mean
but why is that I mean other than our
very good vacation policy oh we don't
really need to make you some oh no I
think it's the fact that um it's a good
team of people who are truly passionate
about making it
h and and i think the change that we're
trying to make is such scale right with
25 people right now and we're heading
4.5 million unique users a month and
that's that's huge scale and I get
excited about the fact that the things i
do will impact the this group of this
group of students are actually not just
students right people around the world
who just want to learn something
different and what's your sense of I
mean like the summer camp this is going
to affect me you know under on the order
of 100 students this summer how does
that affect the scale well i think i
think we are very clear in our minds
that yes it is targeted towards this sub
hundred group of students right now but
the intention is that these learnings
that we find from the summer camp will
be scaled out on a website and therefore
available to the millions of students
yeah josh is impaired that's how we're
skip that's how are scaling the findings
from the summer camp and what's your
sense i mean where do you want to see
all of this going me especially you are
a teacher in Singapore a lot of people
hold up Singapore is kind of and it does
seem like they have a very good
education system I mean what do you
think it was working there what would
you like to see more of what do you
think well I mean I think in general
right it just as a teacher whether
you're in Singapore in a good education
system and I was teaching a fairly good
school but even then you had level of
disparity even within the classrooms and
o'clock and across the classrooms and I
always felt that when I went into the
classroom rules like you know you just
give a big just sort of side there you
go all right everybody you know follow
me and your life just come on everyone
let's learn math together right and it
was hard even in a really good school
with very good students because you knew
that you were addressing the needs for
that student you knew that student was
getting lost you knew that student was
bored but you're trying your best to do
all of that and just perform in front of
the class and keep everyone entertained
in 50 minutes that you got right um I
think regardless of where the teacher is
they all you know many teachers have
this is have this issue that they have
to deal with and I think Khan Academy
helps you do that quite a bit right
because you eliminate the fact that you
need to have to entertain the entire
class in one way and one way only like
everyone gets to go at their own pace
and then you can track where everyone is
so you can inter mediate because
otherwise it's just it's it's hard to
understand where
is that you really should focus in your
time yeah yeah very cool